[Musique]
le pib de la dominique et l'un des plus
faibles au monde pourtant sur cette
petite île des antilles les projets
hôteliers de luxe se multiplient
inauguré en 2019 jungle bay propose 120
villes à flanc de falaise avec vue
imprenable sur la mer des caraïbes
à duke comme vous pouvez le voir tout
est très nature c'est ce qu'on appelle
un eco resort et le propriétaire de
jungle bay le décrit souvent comme un
véritable jardin d'éden id
la dominique n'a pas encore d'aéroport
international et sur cette île
volcanique les plages de sable blanc
sont rares mais pour attirer les
investisseurs
ce petit état situé entre la guadeloupe
et la martinique un argument de poids
et investir dans jungle bay donne à
chacun des investisseurs le droit à la
nationalité en dominique
la nationalité de la dominique est à
vendre et c'est l'une des moins chères
au monde pour l'obtenir deux options une
donation de 100 mille dollars pour un
programme social dans le pays ou en
investissement d'au moins 200 mille
dollars dans un projet touristique comme
jungle bay
kenny green est intermédiaire dans la
vente de ces passeports doré
la quasi-totalité de ses clients ne
mettra jamais un pied en dominique ce
qui les attire et ailleurs lire ce sont
des personnes qui ont des nationalités
sujette à des stéréotypes
autrement dit ils ont des difficultés à
voyager ils en sont empêchés par leur
nationalité
les clients de kenny green viennent
principalement d'asie et du moyen-orient
en achetant un passeport dominicain ils
ont accès à plus de 140 pays à travers
le monde y compris ceux de l'espace
schengen pour rassurer ses partenaires
diplomatiques la dominique a mis en
place une série de vérifications censé
garantir le sérieux des candidats and
does week end les documents demandés
vont de la fiche de renseignements jeu
aux formulaires administratifs en
passant par un questionnaire médical et
des certificats de relevés bancaires
complets afin de vérifier l'origine des
fonds
mais ces vérifications sont effectuées
par des organismes privés qui ne font qu
émettre des recommandations
les etats-unis et l'union européenne
s'inquiète de ce manque de transparence
les programmes de citoyenneté par
investissements peuvent faciliter la
criminalité financière
dans une résolution adoptée en mars
dernier le parlement européen préconise
plus de fermeté vis-à-vis des pays qui
proposent ces programmes s'ils perdaient
l'accès à l'espace schengen le passeport
dominicaine pourraient devenir beaucoup
moins attractif
nous suivons la situation de très près
et c'est pour cette raison qu'une part
de la communication et du lobbying que
nous avons à faire avec l'ue et les
états unis et simplement d'expliquer
l'importance de ces programmes pour
notre économie
les revenus du programme de citoyenneté
par investissement représente
officiellement plus de la moitié des
recettes du gouvernement les donations
dans les programmes sociaux grâce auquel
on peut obtenir un passeport pour
seulement 100 mille dollars permettent
de construire des hôpitaux des écoles ou
encore des logements sociaux comme ici à
roseaux la capitale
si il y à la cuisine
la salle à manger c'est génial superbe
la technologie moderne
corinne à john s'est installé en avril
dernier dans cet appartement flambant
neuf
noël en avril c'était noël en avril
grâce à ce type de programme social le
parti au pouvoir bénéficie du soutien de
la population la citoyenneté de la
dominique étant une ressource illimitée
le gouvernement ne regarde pas à la
dépense
laloyer pas de loyer on paye juste
charge
les fonds du volet social du programme
de citoyenneté par investissements sont
gérés par mmc eu cette société privée
basée aux émirats arabes unis
développent des projets immobiliers pour
le gouvernement je vous auriez dû voir
l'inauguration
les gens étaient tellement heureux il
pleurait il pleurait vraiment
en tout mmc eux gèrent plus de 22
chantiers dont celui du futur aéroport
international estimé à près de 350
millions d'euros cela représente une
grande partie des commandes publiques
attribué sans appel d'offres
on est très connu ici et je suppose que
les gens nous aiment bien
cette mainmise de la société mmc eux est
l'une des principales inquiétudes de
l'opposition à dominique
le premier ministre nous a dit que cet
argent qu'ils collectaient pour
construire des logements sociaux en 2010
ne passait pas par le budget de l'état
comme la loi l'exigé cet argent est
placé sur un fond de garantie à
l'étranger
officiellement la vente de passeports a
rapporté 1,2 milliard de dollars à la
dominique entre 2017 et 2020 en se
basant sur le nombre de certificat de
naturalisation délivrés l'opposition a
fait ses propres calculs
il y à
4,2 milliards de dollars issus de la
vente de la citoyenneté dominicaine qui
ne se trouvent pas dans le trésor public
ce à quoi nous avons affaire c'est un
cas flagrant de détournement de l'argent
qui appartient la dominik moll
england banega
le gouvernement nie ces accusations
et si le chef de l'opposition soutient
le programme de citoyenneté par
investissement il craint que ce manque
de transparence ne nuise à la réputation
du pays
c'est un sujet d'inquiétude pour les
gouvernements responsables partout dans
le monde vous ne pouvez pas avoir des
pays qui vendent des passeports qui
deviennent des outils dans les mains des
criminels pour leur permettre de voyager
sans problème à travers les frontières
internationales grâce justement aux
privilèges accordés au passeport
dominicain
il existe actuellement plus d'une
centaine de programmes de citoyenneté ou
de résidence par investissements à
travers le monde dont plusieurs d'entre
eux dans les caraïbes
[Musique]